he-hello good they kind of gate Turtles
gonna try and follow it up he does have
old he gets get outta my all tantrums
gonna miss you go sit down is we're
gonna keep Tracy for it should be a kill
dial
fifty thousand kills there it is one
thousand kills for turtle
[Applause]
get rid of set enough lip hospitals now
actually watching keith's gets popped in
retargeting go dance wit get a guys
think of that piles one thousand one
[Music]
everyone has full open some kinds of
splashes we have actually only a lot of
moisture Everett he's gonna be able to
find the oven if it goes to the bandage
sauce he doesn't really want to waste
too much crab patron that Burris takes a
bit of damage but they've got sitting
out they could go for this one there's
the front sorry thank you very low that
one still get the youth kisses I'm only
there it is he goes out crescendo hits
the entire complexity though cami turn
it around well sell out the packs just
hitting hitting one after the other
there's a double girlfriend now the one
is Josie that's gonna feed him a triple
kill mi a son that's going to be a
Quadra kill turning in the past ago
front you 101 it's gonna be the best day
careful beautiful play wild self step
you know camp
you have something's after right now
because enrollment because they did burn
the panthéon ultimate took almost no
damage how much harass can TSM throw
back at them I think this isn't actually
very dangerous dragon if they tried it
rinse and repeat get that stun down from
pantheon a great cyclone from the odd
one to the backside turtles for superior
oh wow this is a wall 2 4 2 1 miss
lasses today across the spring split
here in na Pearson looking to go down
now great coordination and control and
it's always a potential right here TSM
of course they're they're playing the
Washington plate is low here they got a
hard engage they're on to Edward he's
just exploded we look at the hurdle so
those flashes are the basic get the kill
here but he's now alone and that's not a
Thresh on a CV can't get over the wall
but they're at the few flashes forward
this is for you while turtle that one
came from an almighty flash into the
base what was going through your head I
was getting really bored I usually play
a lot of solitude it's been slowly with
the game gets really boring I'll usually
just splashing through crazy stuff and
now we start dropping like hi
good let's add Bobby in well as a double
GU be a triple Julie yes he will
executable can you get the quad to
Waukesha Jesus honey yes papa
gotta get the best come on John Bangkok
he'll straight away there it is
beautifully done wow so well he was the
one who was caught but he turned it
around with the help of his team he's
going to keep them there for the fight
he is almost locking down five members
they don't want to move they're all
magnetically attracted to him and dyrus
is to focus for cloud nine right now
this could give wildturtle the rest of
team enough time to do damage but cloud
nine is just to think I actually flashed
in from behind the fight here to just
pop wild turtle and she was trying to do
this fight and once that happened the
fight was over but he knew the damage
would be too much all their up on the
front line by himself they locked out
Pearson does you have anything else to
say with plans in the fight he goes back
for the shots on the cross but he's too
tanky to go down immediately
earlier on enforce eternal turtle coming
up big on the other end of the fight
deja vu from crazy on guys no don't rip
off turtle
what's up a SoCal out here they lock
them up the cleanses out squad take them
down plus boys very close do get to the
turn up for the triple why are you I'll
get the triple kill oh my god one more
shot no yes you get there okay you guys
are oh my god turtle siren is ridiculous
dyrus
takes a pentakill save the Nexus again
pieces this is definitely spent the
specs of the Alamo I have ever seen
second League of Legends Exodus
like that but lmq like he said we're
waiting for this Baron completely dark
they go for the engage that's AG leave
down it's just a half a second dyrus
tries to get in Bjork is not even
getting the ulti until half of the team
is down and that means there's enough
focus for Pearson to draw only trundle
doesn't get over the wall there has the
plan but he goes down anyway still
grabbing as far for nice but impulse
going for a quick push on this one
Janna and jinx are toppling sends the
rocket out for a bit of scouting and
maybe some damage huh oh that almost
never works
wow that was a great play by him the
topple almost taking down beards in wild
turtle classic part the bow
turtle goes hard on this one the rest of
the team has the chance to follow but
they were knocked up by the howling gale
turtle
being too far forward using all of his
escapes to enter gets himself killed a
wild turtle on his way out of the base
he still has no flat cast be careful
about that but they caught who team and
whom he's got a scuffle to by sometimes
Onias is not gonna down here yet enough
Damon still under Unni and they pick him
up Erik and land darshan to dive this
one and he gets it one for one topping
aesthetics pigeon running away low
health tumbler double kill for wild
hills ass and have been knocked back by
bow bow sir he's getting all the damage
across a Quadra kill already four wild
turtles and let's it go to carry this
game and immortals can take whatever
they want
turtle shows us late but he is huge when
he does get the Penta kill for the team
it's going to mean Baron again and an
insane lead for more
I'm doing some pretty normal bookkeeping
right now actually well over the wall it
is not good good bye all right
Wow to zero yes then take the lead in
the Battle of the Atlantic and the lords
explosion doing a bit of damage but
while turtle is still uncool sneaky
running away but also dodge this but
Russia's back hit from the cube but here
comes curtain call what other has to
block this he's going to get close
doodie head against the crap about to
stop blocking it and he goes back in for
speaking Russian balls
unstoppable maybe even literally thread
off going at turtle one versus three and
he takes three of them down our dive
shower dock after tower dive punished
heavily by immortals and they're getting
right back in this
yes but also some weird mistakes while
turtles got executed by the top lane
turret he wasn't saying to finish after
30 we're just looking mid late you
cannot overlook double it stepping down
wild turtle big shoes to fill this year
he's gonna have proved himself he just
came back for getting himself healthy
parties all holly leaves toady so nose
to dry for a quick second and now it's
going to be all a - cuz he's dead Oh
kills all over the map but it's a triple
for wild so fertile with a huge triple
you know there it is the great turtle
yeah we can get you the fans thanks for
supporting him over the years saw your
it's all your doing
yeah but overall record setter he's like
a thousand and hungry every time now
that you get to kill you can say a new
record I will keep you do that old tank
ruptures gonna miss the goats is done as
well gonna keep changing for it should
be a killed bottle
fifty thousand kills there it is
1,000 killed for colonel
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button